[Music]
shutter island' and when I saw the
trailer for this movie I did not think
Martin Scorsese Alfred Hitchcock No
maybe but now it's Chris AZ but that
doesn't make the movie bad though
shudder Islands based off a novel by the
guy who wrote Gone Baby Gone in Mystic
River and personally I've liked all the
movies based off his books now for those
of you who remember shutter island' was
supposed to come out last November but
was pushed back to February but what the
studio said was financial reasons
because the studio would just never
light it was about that in any case it's
out now so any shutter island' DiCaprio
plays a US Marshal who along with his
new partner have been brought to shutter
island to investigate the mysterious
disappearance of one of their patients
after that welcome to Arkham Asylum e.x
no I really did enjoy this movie but for
me any movie that takes place in the
puzzle Factory has an automatic creepy
factor do it and this place is
definitely creepy it just has that
creepy loony bin look to it you know the
one I'm talking about where like the
walls were made of wet slimy moldy brick
and he's probably some creepy mad doctor
scientists and a dungeon somewhere
flipping electrodes to his nipples bring
him back the Frankenstein monster you
get the idea creepy and that's pretty
much put DiCaprio thanks to this place
the mad doctor scientist nipples thing
and after a little investigating you get
the feeling if there are secrets and
shutter island' that are not being said
and dicaprio was determined to blow the
lid off this place as for the acting it
was pretty solid in this movie ben
kingsley plays the head psychiatrist in
shutter island and the guy's an
accomplished actor what can you say I
mean he wanted Oscar for playing Gandhi
then again he was also in the Love Guru
but lucky for us this was one of his
good roles you don't know if he's just a
really good doctor or a secretive douche
but whatever the case Ben Kingsley
played the role very well I got that man
to say that DiCaprio was also really
good and it puts just funny because I'm
a guy and that means there was a time I
I just hated DiCaprio I hated him with a
passion because every girl would throw
their panties at any movie he was in
because he was in a movie about a
sinking boat and you have a secrets out
every guy on earth after Titanic just
hated DiCaprio because we just wanted to
be him I don't know but it's safe to say
that for the past few years he's
established himself as a really good
actor and he shows it in this movie so
aces to you DiCaprio little bastard and
Mark Ruffalo plays DiCaprio his partner
which is funny because I didn't think
Ruffalo made movies anymore and he was
okay anyone could have played his role
oh I guess they had to get a guy that
wouldn't
overshadow DiCaprio we wouldn't want
that but I mean you're not really
watching the movie for Ruffalo you're
too busy admiring the crazies this movie
does a really good job at making you
feel like you're on an island full of
people who are just out of their minds I
mean you can just see it in the trailer
you got Rorschach from Watchmen I like
you you got Casey Jones from Ninja
Turtles with a big ol scar across his
face and that creepy Smeagol looking
chick from the trailer who's all like
but there's no big Indian smother and
Jack Nicholson with a pillow creepy
people though no there's talks that this
movie would have been up for Best
Picture and the Oscars had it come out
in November I don't really know about
that I mean if they had a category for
enjoyable psychological thriller that
shows the other side of Scorsese I mean
you'd be up for that for sure I mean
ultimately I'd watch the movie again if
that means anything so after weeks of
so-so movies we have a movie that's head
and shoulders above the rest at least of
the movies that have come out in 2010
and if you've liked what you've seen
here and you're morbidly curious enough
to see more because that's what I do I
make people morbidly curious then click
on the link in the sidebar to see more
and subscribe oh yeah
till next time I'm Jeremy
[Music]